ja mich hat heute ein grüner
finanzminister aufgeregt der grüne
finanzminister daniel meyers aus baden
württemberg frisch im amt hat er einen
aus seiner sicht revolutionären planen
er plant eine anonyme online plattform
wo
bürgerinnen und bürger ihren nachbarn
ihren bekannten vielleicht auch ein
familienmitglied verpfeifen können und
zwar mit dem verdacht der
steuerhinterziehung also man muss sich
das so vorstellen man sitzt zu hause im
garten sind möglicherweise am
samstagnachmittag da wird beim nachbarn
das dach noch mal gedeckt oder es kommt
jemand mit einem spaten in den garten
und will möglicherweise dort arbeiten
also ran ans handy eintippen auf der
online-plattform anonym wohlgemerkt und
die nachbarn schon verpfeifen das geht
nicht das ist eine steuer stasi ich
empfinde das als zutiefst unwürdig von
politikern dass sät zwietracht und es
kehrt eigentlich das verhältnis des
steuerzahlers zum staatsdiener um dann
plötzlich hat mein eindruck der
steuerzahler ist der eigentliche
staatsdiener der mit seinem geld dem
staat dienen soll ich möchte ja nicht
der schattenwirtschaft das wort reden
aber ich bin gegen
denunziantentum und gegen zwietracht und
vor allem gegen misstrauen dass der
staat seinen bürgern gegenüber wo ich
hab was gegen grüne steuer haft ist das
muss ich hier einmal so ganz klar
deutlich sagen ja da ist was dran
natürlich ist es geht nicht darum zu
sagen schwarzarbeit ist super und das
wollen wir jetzt wirklich leicht machen
es ist glaube ich ein konsens dass das
wir da ein problem haben und dass das
auch eingedämmt werden muss aber ich
halte das portal was da jetzt in
diskussion steht für das absolut falsche
mittel zum einen ist es ja so dass ist
ja auch jetzt ja schon möglich ist wenn
ich im bunde diese vermutung habe der
arbeitet jemand schwarz dann kann ich
das dann kann ich das auch melden also
das ist ja nicht erst dann wirklich wenn
es ein solches portal gibt das ist
natürlich muss man glaube ich einfach
ganz klar sagen und dann vergrößert ist
ja die ursachen warum haben wir denn
soviel schwarzarbeit das hat ja das hat
ja gründe wir haben ein system was
gerade auch den übergang vom transfer
system also für jemand der staatliche
leistung bezieht der daraus möchte ist
nicht ganz einfach macht und da ist es
manchmal sehr vielleicht schwarz zu
arbeiten
als ganz klar nebenjob oder eine kleine
beschäftigung anzugeben dafür regulär
steuern abzuführen da habe ich mal
weniger als im transfer bezug und
solange wir das nicht hinbekommen so
lange wir diese ungerechtigkeiten gerade
in diesem bereich im übergang von von
transfersystem in zurück in die
selbstständigkeit auf eigenen beinen zu
stehen sondern wir das nicht hinbekommen
wird es auch immer viel schwarzarbeit
geben und das da macht man sich als
politiker viel zu einfach indem die
einfach etwas zu leisten und sie haben
sie auch vollkommen recht dass sät
zwietracht anstatt meiner auf meine
hausaufgaben zu machen und ich habe
ehrlich gesagt denn durch krone auch
genug von
zwietracht gesät wurden diesem land das
ich hab das ja auch erlebt und in vielen
bereichen das da demontiert wurde wenn
er in einer wohnung vielleicht zwei drei
leute so viel zusammengesessen habe ich
finde das furchtbar ist eine ganz
schlimme entwicklung und das wollen wir
nicht noch befördern es dreht halt
vieles um also das ist glaube ich der
kern und wir sehen ja eigentlich dieses
land ist reich an steuereinnahmen im
jahr vor der korona krise also 2019
haben bund länder und gemeinden 800
milliarden euro und ein gerichten also
dass man jetzt aber der punkt ist ja
eigentlich geht es doch gerade auch den
grünen immer um den um eigentlich das
melken des steuerzahlers also wenn er
das geld nicht freiwillig quasi rüber
schiebt dann muss ich erstmal
steuersätze und es gibt permanent darum
zu sagen ja nicht noch mehr geld für den
staat generieren das irgendwie
bemerkenswert das korreliert auch mit
den sozial- und staatsausgaben die wir
haben und mir fehlt eigentlich das
gegenteil mal zu sagen gibt es könnte
eigentlich auch ab schichten als staat
mir fehlt auch mal der dank an den
steuerzahler denn der ermöglicht
überhaupt diese ganzen ausgaben das
gegenteil ist der fall der steuerzahler
wird eigentlich unter generalverdacht
gestellt das ist eine total gefährliche
entwicklung
mich hat das auch enttäuscht weil wir
damit aber es kommt ja eigentlich aus
war vorher in berlin tätig und hatte
einen ausgezeichneten ruf und dass er
mit seiner nummer um die ecke kommt ist
ein bisschen traurig aber ich fürchte
wir treffen nicht die stimmung im volk
ich erinnere mich noch in
nordrhein-westfalen norbert
walter-borjans war finanzminister
und kaufte steuer cds aus der schweiz
also die da kriminelle gezogen hatten
und alle haben leitartikel das darf der
staat nicht machen das ist ganz schlimm
die scheibe hat gesagt das geht nicht
und als er einmal hatte sind auch die
unions finanzminister gekommen und haben
ihm teil der millionen die er die
kriminellen gegeben hat zurück gegeben
damit sie auch die daten bekommen und
dann war walter borjans so populär dass
er da draußen noch ein bestseller
gemacht hat oben spd vorsitz ich fürchte
und das kommt mehr modelle geben ja ich
fürchte ich fürchte das wird nicht eine
grüne ideen bahn würden begeben
werden ich komme eigentlich wäre es
nicht machen
hat man irgendwann sagen kann die größte
lump im ganzen land das der steuer die
nun ziehen denn es gibt ja so was
tatsächlich schon in manchen gemeinden
natürlich kann ich oder wie auch immer
auch andere
anzeigen auch anonyme anzeigen wenn sie
steuer wenn ich den verdacht habe das
ist da steuervergehen gleich steht das
sogar zum beispiel auf der seite habe
ich mir angeschaut und da gibt es sogar
eine frage geht das finanzamt auch eine
anonyme anzeige nach warum fragt sich
das finanzamt bayern selbst diese frage
natürlich im leuten zu zeigen ist es
möglich und dann steht da ja aber
namentliche anzeigen besitzen in der
regel größere bedeutung weil sie
rückfragen ermöglichen aber genau es
gibt zeit schon die möglichkeit eines
frau suding gesagt hat das fand ich sehr
spannend das habe ich auch erlebt dieses
denunzianten tun was gekommen ist mit
corona über durch durch solche
anschuldigungen verdächtigungen auch
dass man gesagt hat hier sind drei leute
zu viel die für eine partie die nicht
sein soll jetzt nicht so aber aber
sitzen halt ein paar leute zusammen das
hat unglaublich zugenommen ich will
jetzt nicht sagen dass erinnert wie an
schlimmste zeit die ich selbst nicht
erlebt habe aber das ist so eine tendenz
dahin und wenn das verstärkt wird durch
eine meinetwegen auch gut gemeinte sache
zu sagen okay hier soll nicht geld
hinterzogen werden vom staat steckt
dahinter aber dann stört dass solche
emotionen und auch solche ja vielleicht
verhaltensweisen die einfach nicht gut
der punkt ist ja auch wie geht es weiter
also man kann das ja noch weiter spinnen
wir sind jetzt beim thema steuern
anonymer steuer anzeiger quasi aber was
ist eigentlich mit
anderen themen also du fährst ein
schickes auto aber
das ist kein e auto sondern haut
ordentlich hatte einst war die welt nach
narnia und einem dieser ständigen online
plattform und
immer noch wieder mal zusammengearbeitet
haben genau und ich sagte ja und dann
stinkt das immer so und ich sitze
nachmittags im garten und das raue ist
wer zu blöd ich gehe auf die plattform
wo man jetzt dann künftig umweltsünder
anonym anzeigen könnte was ist
eigentlich mit sprach sündern
politischen oder falschen aussagen im
politischen spektrum nach rechts und
nach links kann man die irgendwann auch
anzeigen also wir kommen ja in ein von
corona übersteuern hin zu einem den
ozeanen tun oder zu müssen wird ein weg
bereitet den halte ich für extrem
gefährlich
[Musik]